FIRST MALE VOICE >> Okay. We are here with
our YouTube Europe team--
SECOND MALE VOICE >> Hey!
FIRST MALE VOICE >> That's Ed, Neuer, Jeff
and Arvin. Ed, tell us a bit about-ah-about
what's goin' on here.
ED >> This is, as described by one proponent
of YouTube, it's been a slaber-hit of Davos.
This is-ah-the Davos question, which-ah-has
been a fantastic innovation between the world
economic forum and YouTube. Um-we have put
the Davos question-what is one thing that
countries, companies or individuals can do
to change the world in 2009-out to the general
public, out to the YouTube community. We've
got some great responses and we've played
these to-ah-to world leaders here. And not
only that [PANNING AROUND THE ROOM], got them
all to respond to-ah-or as many as we can-to
make them post their own responses to the
Davos question.
So the guys here have worked-worked incredibly
hard-ah-pulling people in, pulling leaders
in and it really has been just great--
JEFF >> We wrestled them to the ground, tied
them up--
FIRST MALE VOICE >> Jeff, how does it work?
Okay, tell me how this whole thing works.
JEFF >> How this all works is we sit there
and stare at people's chest to see their tag
because we don't necessarily recognize their
face. [CLOSEUP OF JEFF'S NAMETAG]
ED [HOLDING JEFF'S NAMETAG] >> That's Jeff-that's
Jeff ten years ago. Look, he had hair. [LAUGHTER]
FIRST MALE VOICE >> Oh. Wow, kinda--
NEUER >> Jeff's extreme charm and wit attracts
a lot of people. [BACKGROUND VOICES, JEFF
HOLDS UP HIS NAMETAG.]
FIRST MALE VOICE >> So you were essentially
saying you approach people. Is that what you
were saying?
JEFF >> It's a nice way of putting it. And
when you go out there and you look there and
you sit there and say, "Oh, my goodness, who
could that be? That is Bono." And then you
wrestle him to the ground--
ARVIN >> ...which isn't very far away.
JEFF >> --and then you bring him a part and
then you hit play on the recorder and say-you
say, "Answer the g------ question." And then
he does.
FIRST MALE VOICE >> Arvin, what's the-ah-hit
so far? Who's your-who's your favorite person
who's answered the Davos question?
ARVIN >> My favorite person, personal favorite
was Shimon Peres for one reason. Because he
sat in front of the computer-ah-he said, "Hello,
YouTube," and then he expected the computer
to ask him a question. So he did that, and
then Ed had to ask him the question. That's
my personal favorite.
JEFF >> He had to disguise his voice to make
it sound like the computer. [BACKGROUND LAUGHTER]
He pulled that whole, like-ah-2001 Space Odyssey
voice on there.
ED >> But, okay. In all seriousness though,
and we have Peres' posting. And then-ah-Ahmed
Mussa has responded directly to Shimon Peres
on YouTube. This is--
FIRST MALE VOICE >> Can you tell me first
who Ahmed Mussa is
?
ED >> He's the head of the-ah-
Arab League of Nations, is that right?
JEFF >> Yeah.
ED >> And-ah-he-ah-I mean to get that sort
of interaction between world leaders and in
a bit of a window into the YouTube community
has just been amazing. So there've been some
truly prominent people here who have been
exposed to YouTube for the first time and-ah-they'll
be using it again. So it's been a huge hit
and we hope that the YouTube community out
there has-has appreciated the response of
the world leaders, the most influential people
in the world, who are listening to you guys.
So it's amazing.